in northern Minnesota the Brule River
comes to a forked waterfall one side is
well behaved goes over the edge and then
flows downwards to Lake Superior the
other side goes into a big hole at which
point half of this river flows into this
massive hole at which point it is never
seen again all we know is that half of
the Brule River disappears into the
devil's cattle people have tried to
figure this out scientists have dumped
dyes hundreds of ping pong balls
GPS trackers people just shoved logs
into this hole the expectation is that
it would come up somewhere in Lake
Superior but none of the things people
have tried to track the flow of this
water have worked they simply disappear
what is especially frustrating and
confusing for geologists is that this
really shouldn't be happening
geologically speaking northern Minnesota
is full of holes sometimes called
kettles or cauldrons these are places
where harder rocks get trapped in a
softer depression they swirl around
around around and they sort of carve
these deep potholes
these can be big they can be 30 feet
deep plenty large enough to suck an
unsuspecting swimmer to their demise but
what they don't do is turn into miles of
underground tunnel if all of this were
happening in say limestone it would make
perfect sense the water would have
eroded a passageway and created its own
kind of tunnel but this isn't limestone
it's a much harder rock called rhyolite
and rhyolite doesn't form tunnels at
least not naturally so there's only a
few explanations one possibility is that
maybe there's a fault line there but
this isn't a trickle of water it's half
a rivers worth of water a fault line
would have to be enormous to accommodate
that level of water and there's no
evidence for a fault line anywhere near
there there's a second theory maybe
maybe
the kettle has drilled far enough down
that it had a lucky encounter with a
lava tube left there for millions of
years before but there's a small problem
Riley doesn't make lava tubes and even
the basalt which is far far below it
wasn't the right kind of lava flow to
create such a tunnel in a lot of ways we
know the answer the river isn't defying
physics you know it's flowing downhill
and almost certainly ending up in Lake
Superior the thing that has everyone
frustrated and confused is how and the
harder that scientists and geologists
tried to solve this mystery and then
fail the more mysterious Devil's kettle
becomes where's that water going where's
it going subscribe here and watch more
videos here this is really this one it
wasn't worth